WROTE IT AND YOUR PAPER RAN IT.
THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME ON.
>> Tucker: AND SET A BREAK OUR
DEPENDENCE ON CHINA, THE
CORONAVIRUS PARADOXICALLY HAS
INCREASED AT MANY PLACES.
DOZEN OF AMERICAN STATES ARE
USING CHINESE DRONES
MANUFACTURED BY DJI, A CHINESE
COMPANY TO MONITOR CITIZENS FOR
SOCIAL DISTANCING.
THERE IS A MASSIVE PROBLEM WITH
THIS.
AS MATT GAETZ IN FLORIDA SAYS,
HE IS PRESSURING THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
APART FROM THE CIVIL LIBERTIES
WHICH ARE IMPORTANT, WHY ARE
THESE DRONES DANGEROUS?
>> CHINA IS MASSIVELY EXPLAINING
A TROJAN HORSE BACK OPERATION
AND OUR COUNTRY, AND YOUR LOCAL
POLICE DEPARTMENT MAY BE
UNKNOWINGLY HELPING THEM.
THE UNITED STATES ARMY, THE
DEPARTMENT OF INTERIOR, THEY
BANNED THEIR USE OF THESE DRONES
CITING VULNERABILITY AND
POTENTIAL VALUE FOR OTHER
COUNTRIES.
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
WROTE A SCATHING REPORT THAT
SAID CHINA SPECIFICALLY GOES
AFTER LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THEY DID SO BEFORE THE
CORONAVIRUS SO THAT THEY COULD
GET KEY INFORMATION TRANSMITTED
TO THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT, AND
THEN OUR OWN DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY WROTE THAT
THIS IS PRECISELY THE
INFORMATION WE ARE WORRIED THAT
CHINA MIGHT SELL TO TERRORISTS.
EVEN BEFORE THE CORONAVIRUS
TUCKER, YOU HAVE THIS COMPANY
REDUCING THEIR PRICES FOR DRONES
BY 70%.
THEY DROVE U.S. MANUFACTURERS
OUT OF THE MARKET AND SINCE THEY
CORONAVIRUS, THEY’RE OPENLY
BRAGGING THAT THEY HAVE JUST
DONATED THESE TROJAN HORSE GIFTS
TO OVER 22 STATES, OVER A
40 MINUTES OF POLITIES.
WHEN I TALK TO THEM AND
MY OWN INVESTIGATION, THEY SAY,
IT’S NO BIG DEAL, WE FLY THEM
AROUND THE PARKS AND TELL PEOPLE
TO DISPERSE.
WE MAKE SURE PEOPLE ARE SOCIAL
DISTANCING.
THE INFORMATION THAT IS BEING
COLLECTED ASK OUR NATION MORE
VULNERABLE AND I BELIEVE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL WITH THE
AUTHORITIES HE HAS SHOULD
IMMEDIATELY GO AROUND THE ENTIRE
FLEET OF DRONES USED BY U.S.
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND WE SHOULD
NOT BE SPIED ON BY OUR OWN
GOVERNMENT AND GIVING THE
INFORMATION TO A FORMER
GOVERNMENT.
>> Tucker: I HOPE YOU STAY UP
LATE EVERY NIGHT UNTIL YOU GET
THAT DOWN.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT COULD BE
DONE VERY QUICKLY AND THAT NEEDS